so today I'm being turned into storm I
get to become Wolverine today
like if I'm storm I'll be better than
any rapper because I will literally make
it rain come on I think it's gonna be a
really cool like empowering experience
to vicariously live as a superhero well
when I was in elementary school I was
diagnosed with scoliosis which is
curvature in the spine so then I had to
get spinal fusion surgery done in the
sixth grade and the procedure was to get
metal fused to your spine it was about a
year after the first x-men movie had
come out and so my friends started
calling me Wolverine which was really
cool transforming that into something
that made me feel sort of powerful and
unique I'm watching an episode of Wonder
Woman to get in the spirit she was like
one of the only female like black
superheroes growing up it was awesome to
see someone that looked like me he's so
tough and he exudes such confidence and
just badassness doesn't feel very
Wolverine to be getting primped like
this but Wolverine don't get them
watching Wonder Woman as a kid made me
excited for puberty I was like maybe I'm
gonna look like Wonder Woman that didn't
happen and here we are
oh my gosh yeah having massive claws
just makes me feel like the rules don't
apply to you I feel like I look hey guys
but could I take someone that's probably
not because I can't move in the field at
all makes me feel so strong I mean I
could do
those are just like kind of sleek and
sexy being a badass was allowed and it's
just such a cool feeling to just be like
yeah the world go pure self I don't care
what you think
you know it's not the nicest sentiment
but it makes you feel cool